Fin vinst hela tiden.
Ni säljer lite krånglig utrustning.
Skulle man kunna säga att ni är som gymkompaniiet fast bättre?
För ni har en snabbare tillväxt, ni har bättre lönsamhet och...
Det ser bara finare ut helt enkelt.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Filip Gunnarsson till podden och det är han som har grundat och äger företaget PgTech och AB som säljer, ja jag ska försöka förklara det som tillbehör till lastbilar.
Kan du förklara för oss Filip vad ni gör egentligen?
Det ska jag absolut försöka göra.
Vi konstruerar, tillverkar och säljer tillbehör utöver sin till lastbilar.
Då är det absolut jobbsakt, tunga lastbilar.
Vad är en lätt lastbil?
Jag tror att det är under 12 ton tror jag.
Eller om det är 8 ton, jag kommer inte riktigt ihåg.
Har ni ett litet frakt för folk som kör vanliga bilar?
Nej, absolut inte.
Det är bara våra kunder som är...
era kunder har ett frakt för folk som kör vanliga bilar?
Nej, absolut inte.
Vara våra kunder är de som kör de tunga lastbilarna.
De har ofta sett på vägen.
Jag kan inte låta bli...
När jag ser på ditt bolag utifrån, så om man går in och kikar på er, så har ni haft en jävligt fin tillväxtresa.
Nu är ni någonstans uppe i typ 80-ish miljoner här på det senaste bokslutet.
Ni har ju vuxit kontinuerligt och ni har ganska fin vinst hela tiden.
Det är bara du som äger.
Dessutom säljer ni lite krånglig utrustning.
Skulle man kunna säga att ni är som gymkompaniiet fast bättre?
Ni har en snabbare tillväxt, ni har bättre lönsamhet.
Det ser bara finare ut helt enkelt.
Ja, det kanske man skulle kunna säga för att vi jobbar ju 10...
Alltså vi har verkligen, jag skulle vilja kolla på ditt lag någon gång.
Det är nog lite samma utmaningar med tungt, långt, brett, manuell bokningar, fakter och väldigt krångligt så.
Ja, så kanske det är.
Kan du förklara för mig hur man gör för att bli så bra?
Jag lägger ändå 98% av min vakna tid typ att tänka på bolaget och jag har ju inga andra intresse.
Jag tycker att jag är rätt nördig, jag tycker att jag har liksom...
Vad är det jag har missat?
Varför växer ni snabbare än mig?
Varför gör ni...
För du har ju inte heller tagit in massa excent kapital så jag kan inte skylla på att ni har gjort det, utan detta är ju grundat av dig och det är liksom...
Det är helägt där.
Vad är det ni gör riktigt jävla bra som jag missar tror du?
Nej men jag tror att...
Eller jag tänker på jobbet konstant, lyssnar in...
Fan, så det är två procent jag missar då?
Det är för att jag tänker bara på den 98 procent.
Precis, jag kan tänka på 99 procent.
Nej men jag är sjukt involverad i alla sociala medieplattformar, vad trendar, vilka profiler som drar uppmärksamhet.
Jag gillar folk, pratar med väldigt mycket kunder.
Jag har flera kompisar som är i branschen.
Jag är verkligen involverad, både våra slutkunder, våra återbekäljare, våra grocister.
Dessutom är jag uppvuxen med lastbilar.
Min pappa har åker i.
Jag har själv varit mekaniker och byggt och utrustat lastbilar och förstår vad kunderna vill ha och vad de vill höra när de ringer oss eller när de e-mailar oss eller vad de vill ha för information på produktsidan eller allt möjligt där.
Hela kedjan liksom.
Det är nog därför vi har blivit så extremt uppskattade på väldigt kort tid.
Och att vi växer fort då.
Vi har liksom fyller en lucka på marknaden kan man säga.
Jag fattar den för jag kan uppleva ibland att att många tänker att de ska starta ett bolag och så funderar de på en bransch och så går de in där för de ser att här ser det ut att finnas bra siffror.
Men då har de ju inte den bakgrundskollen eller den, du vet man inte, nördat ner sig i det 15 år i förväg.
Som du nämner om du är en mekaniker från start, så fattar du ju vad som är krångligt med att sätta fast ett hel ljus.
Det är ju en annan förståelse för produkten.
Finns det någon nackdel med att vara involverad i världen över huvud taget?
Inte ett företag som leder i business sammanhang skulle jag inte säga.
Det är ju bara fördelar.
Sen är det ju kanske så att jag är involverad i för mycket och kan lite för mycket ibland.
Då engagerar jag mig extremt mycket i vissa nya produkter, kunder, som efterfrågningar, alltså allt möjligt.
Det är väl ingen aktier egentligen, det skulle jag inte säga.
Kan du göra det här felet ibland som vi har vid några enstaka tillfällen sett en produkt och jag har också varit i gymbranschen länge och då tycker jag att den produkten är rent krasst, typ halv skit.
Så jag tycker inte att vi borde ta in den men så tar vi in den för att vi får mycket förfrågningar och sen bara helt plötsligt säljer den as mycket och jag fattar inte varför för jag tycker inte att det är rätt produkt att sälja.
Har du varit med om det, att du får en sorts bias för att du har det någonsin starkt?
Det kan ju vara nackert att jag tycker något personligt.
Det tycker inte jag att man ska ha, det tycker inte jag är bra.
Men om man bara tänker bort den tanken att vad är det våra kunder och marknaden vill ha så är det inte upp till mig personligen att bestämma det.
Men det har jag absolut gått på nån sån hit.
Jag har velat ha lite kollegor som har kommit med grejer, att det här borde vi ta in.
Så har jag varit väldigt skeptisk och så har jag gett mig till slut och sen så har det funkat skitbra.
Ger du någon cred då?
Ja, det tycker jag.
Det har inte varit jättemånga gånger men absolut några gånger.
Eller alltså att det har blivit så.
Jag är oftast inte en jättebromskloss när vi pratar bra produkter att ta in eller ta fram.
Är detta ditt första riktiga bolag så att säga?
Ja, det är mitt första riktigt bolag.
Jag har inte ägt eller drivit något företag innan PG Tecta.
Nej, för du var mekaniker innan?
Ja, jag var mekaniker och påbyggare och utrustare och byggde lastbilar på mitt tidigare jobb.
De sista åren där så var jag teamledare för all påbyggnation vi gjorde då.
Och det var väl egentligen där jag såg luckan på marknaden där att kunna erbjuda, eller var ett företag som erbjudde allt det behövde vara för att bygga upp, utrusta och använda lastbilar.
Jag hade alltid problem att när jag skulle bereda och förbereda projekterna, att hitta produkterna, hitta rätt kvalitet, rätt priser och satt alltid med 15, 20, 25 olika leverantörer.
Så det är det vi vill.
Vi vill vara den leverantören jag själv vill handla av.
Hur kan det vara ett problem?
Jag tänker att lastbilstrafik måste ju vara extremt etablerad.
Det är ju någonting som slits jävligt hårt.
Det är någonting som föder hela samhället.
Det är ju det som styr logistiken i samhället på många sätt.
Hur kan inte det redan finnas en jättekonkret upparbetad kedja för att allt sånt bara hanteras?
Jag fattar inte hur den luckan ens kan bli.
Jag är glad för din skuld att den finns, men vad är det som är knepigt med det?
Det är väldigt svårt.
Det är jättesvårt att kunna.
Det kräver väldigt hög kunskap.
Jag skulle bara tillägga att det inte är reservdelar vi jobbar med.
Det är inte bromsar, inte motorer, utan det är pågrunations-
eftermarknad, efter lastbilschancer.
Men det är inte självklart att man bara kan ge sig in i den här branschen om man inte förstår sig på den.
Kan du berätta hur ni satt igång lite?
Eller du satt igång?
Ja, precis.
Jag hade egentligen ingen plan, ingen 100 procent i plan över huvud taget.
Jag var avstrött på mitt gamla jobb.
Jag hade väl mer eller mindre allt bränt ut mig där.
Jag kunde ha väldigt mycket att göra och det var väldigt turbulent.
Jag slutade där egentligen för att ha det lugnt ett år, tänkte jag.
F-skatta lite.
Jag började smida på min idé, att en e-handel tillbör utrustning till lastbilar.
Och se lite vad det tar vägen.
Jag tyckte att det var verkligen att ta det lugnt.
Jag hade ingen erfarenhet av e-handel på något vis.
Men när jag slutade så fick jag extremt mycket förfrågningar om produkter.
Det var om jag ville utrusta lastbilar.
Alla de här kontakterna jag hade på mitt tidigare jobb, fortsatte ringa mig.
Så jag fick det helt enkelt.
Jag kände att det var fortfarande kul.
Men nu fick jag utsamma allt själv istället och göra på mitt sätt.
Jag körde det i fjol.
Jag anställde min första kollega redan efter ett halvår.
Jag var tvungen.
Men när du säger att du bara körde på, var det i början så att du ringde runt till leverantörer, att jag köper ett påbyggnadsljus där och skickar ut det till den?
Hur satte du i gång businessen i början?
Jag hade några bra relationer med tidigare jobb, som jag visste var bra att jobba med.
De var väl de första jag ringde då.
Det var väl några större och större sister i Sverige då.
Men sen i övrigt, jag fick noll respekt när jag ringde eller försökte få tag på någonting.
Jag fick inte ens ett kundnummer på väldigt många ställen.
Och skitdåliga avtal.
Det var jättedåliga rabatter.
Det var ingen som förstod vad jag ville eller vem jag var.
Så det tog fast en, jag tror att det var två, tre år innan vi...
Jag kände att folk förstod sig på vilka vi höll på att bli.
Det var väldigt trögt i början.
Det var inte lätt att sälja någonting till någon annan eller som nyleverantör på marknaden.
Det var hela tiden väldigt skeptiskt.
Hade du bolaget då, eller hette du liksom Filip Gunnarsson enskilda firma och så försökte du sälja?
Gjorde du den klassiska bakgrundsresan?
Nej faktiskt inte.
Jag hade PGTEC avrigg i 2014, men då använde jag det egentligen som att köpt och sålde lite bilar och lite grävmaskiner och lite sånt varor som är av med monser och så hydde jag en liten lokal och så.
Men sen första verksamhetsåret är ju egentligen 2018.
Så innan det så var det ju bara ett lekvård.
Du är inte bara snabbare i tillväxt här på slutet, du har till och med en snabbare startresa i en gymkompani, det är ju ett helvete.
Jag är ju tävlings...
Jag får komma ut och lägga lite punktering framför era grindar eller någonting, bara få sabba lite eller någonting.
Ja, du har kollat på alla bolagen, men då ser det ju som att det har varit...
Eller ja, jag har varit aktiv sedan 2014, men det är använt som Piggitec AB på riktigt 2018.
Det var ju första...
Alltså fjärde februari 2018, och så lanserade e-handeln.
När drog bolaget igång på riktigt?
När var e-handeln up and running?
Så att folk verkligen började lägga ordrar som inte bara ringde dig.
När började du få igång avtalen?
När började liksom saker hända?
Ni fick en riktig lokal, du vet, allt det där.
Ja, jag trodde på riktigt att det skulle börja trilla in ordera dag ett.
Inte en order på fem dagar tror jag.
Jag hade noll koll på det.
Det var skit, jättedåligt med orderingång egentligen.
Förut i trullingen, kommer knappt ihåg.
Det är väl egentligen sedan, jag tror det är tre år sedan egentligen typ, som e-handeln började snurra ordentligt kan man säga.
Det var väl egentligen när jag anställer min kollega Angelica som e-Commercial Manager, alltså som på heltid tog tag i sajten.
Det var väl då vi började takta på och nu går det bara bättre och bättre hela tiden.
Tänkte säga, ni drog igång när lågkonjunkturen slog till.
Ja, precis.
Vi säljer mycket på offert, telefon och mejl.
Det är en sådan bransch.
Man ser produkterna på hemsidan men man skickar ändå ett mejl för att få en offert.
Man skickar ändå ordnen.
Så man kan inte bara säga att det är vren webb-bord idag.
Men den första riktade lokalen, den fick ju faktiskt vår som jacklatur.
Redan i september 2018 fick jag fråga min befintliga hyresvärde om jag ville ta över större lokal.
Det var bara en chansning men vi körde på.
Vi hade typ 150 kvalitat innan i starten.
Skitlitet, jag och min kollega där.
Sedan gick vi upp till 595 kvalitat.
Vi såg ju inte varandra på dagen liksom.
Är det det ni ligger på idag, 595?
Hur fan löser ni det?
Nej, den är huvudbyggnaden.
Men sen har vi också hyrt alla lokaler runtom.
Vi sitter faktiskt med fem kontrakt, fast typ av fyra ställen kan man säga, fast på samma gata inom radiet på hundra meter.
Så det är väldigt spretigt utspritt just nu.
Tre stycken ställen med personal och ett extern lager och sen så är det ett lager som är ihopbyggt med vårt hubbelager.
Kör ni mellan på gatorna då?
Ja, vi kör med vår skåpbil och truck på datan.
Flyttar, alltså större batcher kör vi på ett ställlaget så flyttar vi det till vårt hubbelager när det är så här slut.
Men nu är det liksom fullt.
Vad händer när ni fortsätter växa?
Hur hanterar ni det?
Det kommer ju att fortsätta.
Ja, det är typ en vecka, den dialogen är ju på röka och basistysning.
Vi kollar aktivt efter möjligheter att flytta eller bygga eller hyra lite olika spår själv.
För ni sitter i Borås väl, i Brämult?
Ja, i Borås, i Brämult, ett industriområde där.
Finns det inte as mycket lagelokaler i Borås?
Jo, i Viarebland annat till exempel, men då är de ju ofta så här 15, 20, 25 000 kvadrat.
Det går inte att hitta något riktigt lagom eller som passas i storlek och hyresnur.
Jag fattar.
Jag hoppar tillbaka lite grann här.
Du sa att när, visst var det Angelika hon hette, som började att dro igång e-handeln.
Ajamän.
Vad var det hon gjorde bra där?
Hur fick ni igång det?
Vad behöver lastbilsfolket se?
Dels, nu är det inte detaljnivå, kunde ni här på e-handeln här, men vi började jobba med en SEO-ads-viro, som hjälpte oss med sök mot automering och annonser, hur produkterna ska se ut med allt från information till bilder, analysera mer konkret och aktivt jobba med sajten, kundresan, laddningssider och allt möjligt.
Helt enkelt jobba med den på dagen.
Jag söker på Ljus Lastbil här, och ni kommer upp som första sponsrade, sedan tre av de här gratisanonserna, och nummer två som SEO.
Fan det är ändå rätt hygglig teckning på...
Ja men kul!
Av topp tio som syns så är ni fem av dem.
Det är ändå okej.
Och det är ändå bra konkurrens på just belysning eller Ljus Lastbil.
Ja, jag tänkte jag tar det mest generella ordet jag kan komma på.
Ja, det är all cred till människorna runt omkring.
Hur fan löser ni hela kapitalbindningen?
För du, precis som vi, sitter ju med en rätt bedrövlig hantering av lager.
Och har du en sjukkredit eller massalån eller hur ser, hur bygger du lager?
Det är en sjukt bra fråga.
Ja, när jag läste frågan eller lite före bilden, så tänkte jag tillbaka lite och fatta själv inte riktigt hur vi har lyckats.
För vi har bra omsättning och väldigt låg belåning.
Vi har en kredit på typ 1,2.
Sen har vi stått något lån på typ 2 miljoner.
Men vi är så jävla duktiga på att använda andra springen.
Berätta mer då.
Nej men det här började jag nog för typ 2-3 år sedan kanske.
Då lyssnade jag på någon podd som någon pratade om det här och bara va fan det här måste vi testa.
Jag gjorde det fort liksom för att handla med alla stora leverantörer om förfallodagar och tweet.
Så att jag använde det nästan pinsamt liksom.
Men som koll, om man går från 30 dag förfallo till 60 eller 90, det är ganska stor skillnad.
Och sen då i våran tur att vi ger 15 dagar ut till våra kunder.
Några enstaka har ju 30 såklart då men, och även typ webbårdar med klararna då de avräkningarna är på 7 dagar.
Så att vi har ganska långt spann om vi köper in en vara med 60 dagar förfallo, säljer den med 7 dagar förfalla till våran kund.
Om vi lyckas sälja den i den, alltså inom en hyfsad tid liksom.
Så det är väl typ en av anledningarna men sen att se till att hela tiden tjäna pengar också.
Att ha marginaler för då bygger vi kassan fortare.
Så länge vi taktar omsättning fort i och med att vi har haft en snabb tillväxt, så blir det mycket pengar i snur.
Håller man bara flödet på den så blir det typ som en snävål.
Hur solver du in att du skulle få 60 eller 90 dagar?
För det är ju ingenting man kan bara ringa och säga tja, fixa det.
Vad var din argument här?
Det är ju dels att vi är en bra kund.
Vi har en väldigt bra dialog med kunderna, eller med leveransvärdena.
Och att vi växer.
Ni ser ju att de senaste tre åren har vi köpt CEO såhär mycket mer varje år.
Och vi är en lång term, vi är bland långsiktiga i relation med er.
Och vår affär växer och då kommer er att göra det också.
Så det blir plattvis påvisa någon win-win situation.
Och det har faktiskt inte varit så jättesvårt att säga.
Så vi har kommit i 60 dagar på många sådana standarder.
Ibland 0.45 men till vissa kan vi få enskilda order 90 dagar.
Men då har vi sagt att enskilda fester, inköp, då är det mer okej vi köper såhär mycket av den här, den här, den här, men vi vill ha 90 dagar för att göra så mycket enklare fasa.
Och då får de sälja skitmycket.
De kanske jättestora, har funnits i 25-30 år.
Det är inte så stort för dem, men jättestort för oss.
Hur ser er att inköp ut?
För ni köper från massa olika varumärken gissar jag, och sen så har ni någon sorts, där ni själva, du sa att ni konstruerar, kan ni inte ge dem olika benen och bara förklara lite upplägget där för oss?
Ja men precis, vi konstruerar, vi är ju, alltså två år nu har vi snart tre konstruktörer på heltid, som bara konstruerar våra egna produkter.
Ni har en verkstad, egen verkstad?
Ja vi har egen tillverkning och egna konstruktörer, som bara heltid med det, utvecklar och förbättrar de produkterna vi har.
Men så jobbar vi med andra olika kända varumärken på marknaden som har produkter som vi kanske inte vill ha, vi vill inte ge oss in i det kriget, till exempel belysning.
Det är väldigt...
De har skapat varumärken och så får de folk eller kunderna att tillära dem.
Det är väldigt roligt att se och så, men det är också väldigt pressat eller utsatt, eller det är mycket jobb att komma dit.
Så då var det väl i vitvinnen som var istället.
Men till exempel om vi tar in ett nytt extra just då, då vill vi se till att ha fästet och kabeln och...
Alltså det sakerna runt omkring den.
Och det är där vi tjänar pengarna, men helheten gör ju att vi får en jäkligt bra order.
Vi erbjuder lampan, vi erbjuder fästet, vi erbjuder kabeln, till exempel.
Så det är ganska enkelt i sambandet.
Men på så vis så syr vi ihop helheten till vår kund så att han kan köpa allt han behöver av på ett och samma ställe och få dessutom jäkligt bra hjälp och support.
Spara in på frakter och allt möjligt liksom.
Fan vad nice.
Okej, ni gör framförallt sådana små produkter.
Ni gör liksom inte stora...
På Lastvilla har man bland de här uppfällda grejerna som man lastar timmer inom.
Det är liksom inte sådana stora konstruktioner utan det är sådana...
Nej, precis.
Vi håller oss till lite mindre, stor produkter, lite mer behändigt att hantera.
Mitt gamla jobb var ju det som du beskriver, tippflak, kranar, lastverkslag, alltså mycket sådana stora grejer, otimpliga grejer.
Mycket pengar också binder i sådant också när man handlar med någon.
Vi har ju fokuserat på mindre och större volymer.
Våra produkter är ju absolut stora och skrivande ibland men inte så stora.
Men vi gör ju stora verktygslådor, hydraltankar, stora puttbalkar som sitter bakpå lastbilen när de kör asfalt.
Produkterna kan väga 100-150 kilo utan vidare.
Fan, fan kul att ni har fått igång en sådan produktion.
Hur snabbt gick det innan den betalade av sig?
Fick ni igång den affären direkt eller hur gick första året där?
När ni konstruerade era egna produkter var det liksom, nej det var ingen som ville köpa det innan ni hittade det.
Att man behöver sälja det som en app-sale-grej vid sidan av.
Fick ni igång det från start?
Ja, men några grejer fick vi nog igång med sig fort, men det har man ju blärt sig med åren nu, att lite hur man ska lägga upp det, fysättning, hur ska man presentera, hur ska man få kunderna att fatta att han kan köpa allting hos oss och att han kommer att spara tid och pengar på att göra det till exempel.
Det har väl varit den senare åren.
Men i början, jag vet inte.
Jag kommer inte riktigt ihåg, men jag har försökt på alla möjliga sätt.
Du sa att det var bra.
Men just att betala produktionen där, i början så svetsade jag alla grejer.
Okej, nice.
Det jag hade vald att starta, det var en mj-svets och en tjig-svets och vinkerslit på lokal.
Fan vad proffsigt.
Nu har vi anställda svetsare och montörer, men vi jobbar också väldigt mycket med underleverantörer, LEGO-tillverkare.
När det är volygen på någonting så lägger vi ut den.
Är det krångligt att ta fram produkter rent legalt?
Är det en grej, typ om ni ska göra ett fäste, måste ni skicka in den till 48 certifieringar?
Eller är det bara ett fäste?
Många gånger är det bara ett fäste.
Vi försöker hålla oss till de produkterna som inte blir så krångliga, eller långdragna att ta fram, eller dyra att ta fram.
Så det är det som har varit strategi när man får börja med att hålla oss till dem, för att få snur på firman och omsättning.
För det här gör det enkelt, inga tester, inga kloktester, inget så.
Nu har vi gett oss på en artikel faktiskt nu i våras, som vi har provat på Rise under en längre tid, som vi snart är klara med.
Men det märks ganska tydligt att, shit vilket jobb det var, extremt mycket dokumentation och provningar.
Vad menar det, ni provade på Rise, vad betyder det?
Alltså Rise, Sveriges provningsinstitut, SP.
Det är ju, då har vi gjort ett dragprov, ett tryckprov, och idéns provgick som vi väljade ett provningsrapport för att kunna skicka in, få en ESC-emärkning på produkterna.
Och så är ditt sluttilltid är beslut att ni kommer aldrig ta fram en produkt igen som behöver gå igenom allt det där.
Nej det är det inte, men vi kommer inte göra det, pauserar nog det lite, tills vi har, vi går oss in i det där utan att veta exakt hur alla steg var, och att vi fattar inte hur lång tid det skulle ta.
Det var ganska omfattande.
Ser, säljer ni bara till Sverige eller säljer ni till hela Europa?
Nej, vi säljer, ja men hela Europa kan man säga.
Vi har ju då Sverige, Norge, Finland, Danmark och sedan Europasite.
Vi säljer ju absolut mest i Sverige.
Så står det ungefär för 75% av våran omsättning.
Norge är nog runt 15 och Europa, Tyskland typ 7 eller nånting.
Hur löser ni frakten till Norge?
Jag har velat komma in i Norge i många år, och jag får fan inte till att bli lönsamt.
Kan inte du bara ge mig nyckeln här nu?
Ja, hade jag haft den så hade jag gett den till dig.
Jag har faktiskt inte detaljkoll på det.
Det har min kollega på lag ut.
Fan jag skulle intervjuat honom istället eller henne.
Ja precis, du får gärna fråga honom.
Det är en jätteutmaning, är det verkligen, med Norge.
Men ni skickar styckvis per order, ni skickar inte dit i batch, ni har inget separat lager i Norge, utan ni gör det order per order liksom.
Ja precis, vi har inget lager i Norge.
Vi finns inte i Norge rent fysiskt.
Det var en extrem utmaning i början.
Ja har ni ett bizarrt prispåslag till Norge, vet du det?
Nej, jag tror vi ligger några procent över den svenska prisistan jag vill, för att kunna kompensera lite för att dels att det är mycket mer administrativt, och sen så frakterna är ju dyrare också.
Men det känns inte som att det är ett problem för normer, för de håller på hejvilt.
Fan du låter ju jävligt kontrollerad.
Du är inte såhär, ja men det här har vi koll på, det här har vi gjort såhär, det här har vi...
Vad är det du är riktigt jävla dålig på, eller vart har ni verkligen fuckat upp på riktigt?
Inte såhär, ja jag gjorde lite fel där, men det blev bra, utan bara nej, det här sket sig på riktigt.
Ja, alltså jag är ju så jävla strukturerad och eftertingsam som person, så att ja, jag gillar att ha koll på saker, men något tips som vi har gjort riktigt jävla dåligt, jag vet inte.
Alltså det är klart att vi har gjort massa misstag, herregud.
Men ingenting som har påverkat så jäkla mycket på något sätt, vad jag kan komma på nu.
Alltså vi ja, vi.
Fan vad jag hatar, fan vad jag hatar såna människor.
När jag jobbade som golvläggare, jag var lärling i ett par år som golvläggare, då hade jag en kollega som hette Doran, eller han kallades för det.
Och så mitt första jobb så gjorde jag fel, du vet jag skar sönder en jävla matta.
Och då frågade jag honom, för då sa han såhär, ja så ska du inte göra, gör rätt istället, det var hans förklaring.
Och så sa jag, men vad har du gjort fel?
Och då sa han, nej, tror inte jag har gjort fel någon gång.
Du vet sådär, han hade jobbat med det i 45 år.
Och det var såhär, aha, kul.
Fan bara, ge mig felen så jag fattar.
Okej, vad är ni inte bäst på då?
Vad är det ni jobbar på?
Vi jobbar just nu aktivt på rutiner, instruktioner, ja men flöden i verksamheten egentligen.
Helvete Filip, det måste finnas mer ansträngda grejer ni jobbar på.
Ja fan, jag ser och tänker på det här.
Vad är era flaskhalsar nu inför, snart ska ni slå igenom hundringen här, gissar jag att ni gör dem inte inom ett år, inom två år.
Vad är flaskhalsarna sedan för att nå 150 miljoner då?
Du får inte säga lager yta, för det har vi redan hört.
Ja du, fan jag ska göra, jag ska sätta, från och med nu tänker inte jag spela in den här podden med folk som tillöver.
Nu har jag haft många människor här i podden i rad som har varit sådana jävla a-barn som bara tänker efter före, som gör rätt, som har koll på sina siffror.
Det är ju skitbra för er, vilka fina, bra företag ni bygger, men helt hopplöst för oss andra.
Ja, nej jag fattar det låter ju så men herregud det är ju utfågningar konstant, vi är ju absolut inte perfekta.
Men flaskhals för att nå nästa steg även, det är väl...
Alltså vi behöver väl bli mer folk då egentligen.
Alltså göra och dra på mer grejer liksom, alltså...
Det kommer fan inte på något.
Alltså lokalerna är ju, det fick jag inte säga, men det är ju en flaskhals typ nu.
Vi har liksom inte plats för fler människor och mer varor.
Ni är väl ett gäng anställda idag, vilja minnas...
Jag kommer inte ihåg exakt, men hur många är ni nu?
Vi blir 21 nu.
Vad är...
Vi är 9 och jag kan tycka att det är väldigt skönt, för då har jag liksom koll på alla.
Eller jag liksom vet hur många barn varje person har, du vet.
Och så här, de kommer nog att vara sjuka lite i februari.
21, ni börjar ju nå någon sorts gräns där det är lite grupperingar i gruppen, du vet, de snackar aldrig med dem, men de snackar med dem.
Nej, vi har en jättefin arbetsplats, alla pratar med alla.
Nej så är det inte det, det är säkert någon som inte pratar med någon.
Hur ser du till att bibehålla en god känsla i det här, en god startupkultur och alla är med och bidrar?
Jajamän, det är en jättebra fråga, det är ju en jättevist maning.
Det är ju speciellt när man sitter i olika lokaler, att alla ska lära känna varandra.
Det är ju väldigt många som är nya på jobbet, vi har ju ansett i rekordfart, det är ju inte någon som har, i alla har jag inte känt för andra ett år.
Nej men det är väl att försöka kommunicera och vi har månadsmätning gång i månaden så man informerar lite hur det går och vad som händer.
Men sen att vi försöker ha gemensam lunch och frukost och det går inte alltid, det är trompt vart lunchrum.
Fredagsdrukkostar kör vi alltid, för man bjuder på lite fraller och frukostbete.
Försök kommunicera och involvera alla så mycket som det går.
Men det är verkligen inte lätt just nu.
Ja, hur gör vi egentligen?
Lite aktiviteter, ibland after work.
Nu ska jag på en konferensresa här i Köpenhamn nästa vecka.
Hjulbord, försöker hitta på smått och stort.
Får folk att jobba med andra kolleger, även fast de inte gör samma tjänst.
Känner du dig som en ledare?
Ja, ibland.
Jag har blivit intjästad i den rollen kan man säga.
Jag försöker och jag tror att det blir mycket bättre på den än vad det var för bara tre år sedan.
Vad gjorde du för tre år sedan som du har skalat bort?
Eller vad har du lagt till?
Det har väl blivit mindre och mindre operativ.
Jag sitter ju på mitt kontor nu nästan heltid.
Innan ville jag ju gärna vara med och göra och greja och fixa donor.
Men nu har jag mer insett att jag måste låta andra göra jobbet och låta dem göra misstagande, låta dem testa sig fram.
Jag försöker ta ett steg tillbaka och låta de andra växa och prova och kommunicera med sina andra kollegor.
Vilket är jättesvårt rent personligt och även i en ledare.
Saknar du pillandet eller är det mer att du är perfektionistdriven och vill göra det på ditt sätt?
Fy fan, jag hade väldigt många dagar hellre stått i verkstaden eller typ suttit och konstruerat någon produkt som man ser växa fram och som man stämtar fram den, det är absolut roligast som finns.
Men jag har väl blandat mer och mer att det går, ska vi driva, eller så har vi drivat företaget fram och så går det inte, jag måste fokusera på det jag ska göra och låta de andra göra det.
Kan du inte bara ta in en extern vd som får lösa allting eller någon kollega och så får du bara stå och pilla?
De tankarna snurrar ibland, men jag tycker att jag vill ge det här några år till och känna att jag tror att jag kan bli och göra det bättre, men sen är det lite riskig att ta in en extern vd.
Det är så hållande man har det internt.
Absolut.
Jag fattar det, jag köper det dock.
Min tid är alldeles fastslutad på grund av en extern vd.
Så jag har dåliga minnen.
Jag försöker att förstå att det är en...
Ja, det funkar säkert jättebra i minne och verksamhet, men vi är ganska speciellt uppsatt.
Vad menar du med att ni är speciellt uppsatt?
Nej, men vi konstruerar, vi tillverkar, vi lagerhåller, vi har e-handel, vi har en liten butik.
Det är inte alla e-handlare som har ett tillverkande affärssystem.
Det är ganska komplext på många sätt.
Det är inte ett artikel om rin och ett artikel om brut, utan vi har liksom undranivåer, beredningar, operationslego, allt möjligt.
Innan en artikel är klar.
Man kan inte bara vara duktig på e-handelförsäljning, utan man måste också förstå hur produkten tillverkas.
Man har ju förutmaningar där med allting som har med det att göra.
Säljer ni även era produkter till andra leverantörer?
Ja, det är ju absolut den största businessen.
Det är ju att vi säljer tillbörd, utrustning till andra lastbilsverkstäder och påbyggare.
Det måste ju vara fantastiskt roligt när ni har tagit fram en produkt och det även blir en stor säljare på marknaden, men inte bara er i handel.
Jaja, det är skitkul.
Det är jätteroligt.
Det är skitbra upplägg.
Hur stor del är inte er direktkanal, utan att ni är som grossist?
Ja, jag försöker förklara det.
Vi utrustar ju lastbilar också hos oss.
Vi monterar ju våra produkter och utrustar till kunderna.
Cirka 10-15% står i den delen av omsättningar.
För det är ju lite produktutveckling, prototyp, framtagning och sånt i samma vevar där.
Vi blir väldigt duktiga, vi får prata mycket med kunderna, höra referier och så där.
Men sen är det ju cirka 85% är det försäljning och tillbehörsutrustning som vi skickar till andra verkstäder.
Helvete vad mycket, okej.
Ja, coolt, ni har byggt, ja vad roligt att ni har byggt det på det sättet.
Mm, det är inte så många som vet det.
För vi marknadsför inte det riktigt att vi tar in lastbilschassin och bygger upp, men det gör vi mer än många tror.
Men vad är det som är svårt med att nå ut i Europa då?
Är det att hitta verkstäder och återförsäljare ut i Europa?
Har de andra regler eller andra?
För då hade man ju kunnat skala väldigt fort, känns det som.
Ja precis, nämen det med just Europa.
Vi har ju bara varit live i ett och ett halvt år nu tror jag.
Vi har inte gjort, vi har anländit den lite för att se vad som händer.
Varför vi har trafik, vad klickar den på?
Får vi några ordningar för frågor och sådär.
Vi gör ju inget aktivt jättejobb med just Europa, och sajten som fokuserar i Norden just nu.
Norge är ett skitbra vakna för oss.
Det är lika mycket krut på, befintliga slutkunder och återförsäljare.
Det är en liten konservativ och speciell bransch.
Jag är inne på om vi skulle behöva någon slags resande säljare för att bygga relationer ut till oss kunder på ett annat sätt.
För att nu är det typ att reservdelsansvarig eller liknande typ sitter och googlar fram en produkt som hans kund har frågat efter.
Och så får han upp bost där och så är det igång.
Så kanske han får en återförsäljainloggning och sen nästa gång tycker han att det funkar bra och så fortsätter man också.
Så står det vackert som hela vägen.
Eller så är det att hans kund har en lista med artikelnummer från oss eller print screens eller så får han uppsälj och bara köp in det.
På så vis har vi fått in en ny återförsäljare eller någonting för att vi har charmat en slutkund via våra sociala medier.
Men ni har inga uppsökande säljare idag?
Nej.
Är det för att du, lik jag, har ett stort förrakt för dem?
Ja faktiskt, ja.
Ja, nej men det är jag...
Ja, nu har vi...
Det är inte många som kommer till oss och det är för att jag har sagt till min kollega som tar dem samtalen att du kan sitta och prata med dem flera en gång om dagen.
De vi jobbar med, de vi har i relationen och som får komma en gång per år.
Det ligger inte massa tid på det och vi har inte vackert tid på det utåt heller.
Så jag vet inte vad som skulle hända om vi skulle börja göra det.
Men det ligger väl egentligen på mig att jag skulle antingen anställa någon eller göra det själva.
Men fan det funkar ju bra ändå.
Vi snurrar på bra utan att vi gör det.
Så det är väl kanske nästa seg att kolla på.
Så anställda en utbildning.
Men erkänna att det bara är en personlig, det är egentligen en personlig preferens.
Du vill inte ha en säljkår.
Nej, mycket så är det faktiskt.
Grund och bostad är det absolut så.
Jag tycker att vissa, genom åren, som man blir lite utsatt för eller vad man säger, fan, det är så jävla tråkiga.
Det är inte många jag har snackat med om att säga så.
Det är några stycken.
Ja, nu är det hård rövel.
Jag ber om ursäkt för alla som säljer här, men fan, ni vet ju om hur svårt det är i rutten, den branschen är, det är lugnt liksom.
Men fan, det var någon som ringde till oss och undrade om han kunde börja som säljare hos oss, så jag tänkte att jag ska ta det här samtalet ändå.
Så satt vi oss ner och hans första fråga var vilken bil kan jag få?
Jag kände bara fan, du kommer inte passa in här kompis, det här är inte...
Fattar precis vad du menar.
Det är inte din första fråga.
Nej, jag fattar precis exakt vad du menar.
När du tittar tillbaka på bolaget nu, det har gått några år liksom, och ni har byggt upp en rätt tung verksamhet.
Ni har fyllt alla husen i kvarteret, så snart får ni börja ge dig ner i villor och sånt där, bara för att få plats med någon reservdelshylla.
Kan du se något av de här åren som The Good Old Days, vad lätt och skönt det var just det året?
Har du någon nostalgi i minnet så?
Jaja, jag tror det var, vad fan var det?
Av vad det var nu eller vad säger ni?
Det var 25, det var 22 tror jag, 21-22.
Något av åren när det var 21 eller 22.
Då var vi, jag tror vi var sju personer.
Det var nice, tyckte jag.
Då var det inte, det var inte så att alla gjorde allt.
Det var lite uppdelat.
Besluten togs vid frukost eller lunch.
Alltså ganska lätt samt.
Ja men bara kollegor som var kompisar.
Alla, det var väldigt bra stämning.
Och det är fortfarande bra stämning så men det blir ju, det är klart att det är stor skillnad med 21 eller 22.
Alla känner inte varandra och alla är inte lika sociala.
Såklart.
Det var väl, ja men jag tror det var något år där.
Det var riktigt, det var det första minnet jag kom på i alla fall.
Men jag fattar precis, det är ju väldigt så här, man sen var det ofta skitjobbigt också men man har ett så här nostalgiår som var, fan det var rätt chilligt.
Ja men man hade kommit upp över ytan tror jag, det var det jag kände den sommaren.
Man hade lite kontinuerlig omsättning, man behöver inte vara lika orolig på något.
Exakt, jag fattar.
Och hur ser det ut här närmsta åren?
Är det bara samma sak fast i större skala?
Eller ska ni lägga till ännu fler verksamheter, vän, ska ni ut i ännu fler områden, ska ni ta in en säljare till slut?
Vad ligger i korten?
Ja men det som är en next-up nu är väl egentligen att vi håller på med en ny e-endosplatsform som målet är att släppa i januari.
Den vi har nu har man lite för gammal aningar, gör svingelskatteringar på och vi gör en dålig cock-blind till vart affärsvis.
Mycket möjligheter där.
Mycket lättare att skala upp med fler sajter och bättre.
Ja men bättre för kunderna och bättre att vi kan administrera.
Så tanken är ju att vi ska fokusera på att sälja mer produkter till fler kunder helt enkelt.
Jag vet inte om det blir fler sajter nästa år för att se.
Men helt enkelt skala upp.
Gå utanför Norden på ett bättre sätt än vad vi gjort innan.
Nya produkter, både våra egna produkter, sitter vi och kontrollerar ständigt nytt och tar fram och även att våra underlaboratörer, alltså grusister, de kompletterar med nya produkter och varumärken i Vetterion också som vi enkelt tar in.
Så det är väl att skala upp.
Vi vill vidare helt enkelt.
Vi är väl över 100.
Kommer nog inte riktigt dit i år men behöver bli nästa år i så fall.
Ja, om jag skulle följa er riktningar, når ni 93 kanske nästa år?
Är det rimligt?
2025?
Kommer ni nå 92-93 år?
Är det där ni kommer hamna?
Jag vet inte, jag tror faktiskt inte det.
Vi hade mål på 100 i år.
Ganska aggressiv tillväxtplan men vi gillar höga mål också.
Men Q1 och Q2 har varit lite trögare än man trodde det skulle vara.
Men nu känns det riktigt bra här inför slutet på året.
Vi har en Black Friday här med och lite sådär.
Men jag tror inte vi kommer upp i några 90 faktiskt.
Men jag har ändå blivit nöjd här nu om vi kommer över 80.
Har ni också Black Week?
Ja, det har vi.
Går man in och köper stänkskydd på Black Week?
Det är hela det lustiga produkten.
Eller ett balansblock.
Ja, tror du eller ej?
Fan jag köpte så jävla billiga förankringsöglor på Black Week.
Jag har aldrig hört den frasen i alla fall.
Det är ju det som är så sjukt i sådana grejer.
Det är ju inte varor man köper heller.
Du kan ju få för dig att köpa ett par nya skor helt plötsligt för att se en annons.
Men vi har ju mycket varor som du inte...
Vi köper ju inte transplantant oftast utan du har ju gått och funderat.
Och så behöver du en...
Vi säljer ju produkter man behöver och saker man inte behöver.
Det är en bra försäljningshälj eller långhelg.
Jag tänkte en sista fråga här.
Du sitter ju med en PG-tecktröja.
Jajamän.
Hur ofta har du kläder som inte är merch?
Äger du några vanliga kläder?
Hur ofta tar du på dig en vanlig stickad kofta?
Nej men det är väl lördagkvällar ungefär.
Alltså på riktigt, jag har bara PG-tecktröja.
Jag ser det, jag känner det i auran.
Du ser hur många gånger den är tvättad.
Ja exakt, jag känner att du köper kläder i 40-pack, det är din...
Ja, nej kanske inte så gillar jag det inte men jag gillar det.
Jag gillar mina viskar, man vet inte vad som tar på mig i morgonen.
Är du inte också jävligt nöjd att typ Merkels yrkeskläder har börjat sälja skor och strumper?
De har ju vanliga kläder nu så nu kan man i princip märka upp allting så man behöver inte köpa vanliga kläder längre.
Exakt.
Det är ju haft precis arbetskläder, men det är ju snygga kläder, inga konstiga.
Det är ju inga som ser ut som vad man ser ut som.
Men det ser ändå bra ut nu till det.
Absolut, jag tror att resten av världen tänker samma sak.
När de ser dig i din pegetektröja och min junkompagnit så tänker de, fan vad välkläddare de andra männen är.
Det är exakt det de tänker.
Jag ska inte fastna i detta, förlåt det är ett sjukt sidospår.
Philip, stort, stort tack för att du var med i podden och berättade om ditt extremt framgångsrika företag så att jag får känna mig lite, lite sämre idag.
Tack så hemskt mycket för att jag fick vara med dig igen.
Ära.
Vi har inte heller tagit in en massa externt kapital, så jag kan inte skylla på att ni har gjort det, utan detta är ju grundat av dig och det är heläkt där.
Vad är det ni gör riktigt jävla bra som jag missar tror du?